are you a horror fan from Down Under  well I've got some disappointing news if  you are I'm Tony this is a GameSpot news  update and for all the most  spine-tingling game news don't forget to  subscribe  outlast 2 has been banned in Australia  the Australian Classification Board  cites the game's inclusion of sex drug  abuse crime cruelty and violence as  reasons for the ban but developer red  barrels will be able to resubmit for an  r18 plus rating if the game removes its  quote implied sexual violence for what  it's worth last fall's limited demo did  manage to get that hour 18 plus rating  outlast 2 comes to ps4 Xbox one and PC  on April 25th the same day we'll see the  release of outlast Trinity which  includes outlast 1  it's whistleblower DLC and the sequel  and no red barrels hasn't changed its  stance on VR support for the game at  least at launch but for now you can  check out our video on 5 new PlayStation  VR games to look out for  [Music]